ladies if any of these are his favorite
books
run number one anything by stephen king
all these books are over long contain
zero references to the music of john
denver and go nowhere number two the
great gatsby not gonna lie this is like
one of the most basic books you can have
ever heard of a pdf this book contains
only one mention of the music of john
denver that's frankly not enough number
three the odyssey i'm not gonna lie i
enjoyed most of this book it contains
plenty of references to the music of
john denver the only issue is like homer
simpson is like a terrible guy his grind
set is weak also like not writing down
your story how lazy is that number four
the psycho sequel triple feature box set
while this isn't technically a book in
the classical sense you don't really
want your man enjoying these films does
he really think alfred hitchcock's
classic can be improved upon oh wait
it's just sathura it's okay if he
watches this number five literally any
poetry oh it's embodied entitlement
write more words down like there's a
full page show some work ethic william
carlos williams is that really all you
can say about the red wheelbarrow also
his poem about john denver could have
been way better moral of the story if
your man likes to read that is [ __ ] up
stop it